rescue workers are searching for
survivors in a pile of
concrete an Israeli air strike hit a
residential building in central
Gaza girl and her brother are the sole
survivors in this attack that killed
dozens of
Palestinians the Israeli Army has been
ramping up its military action in the
besieged southern city of Han yunas
Paving the way for t tanks and army
vehicles to move deeper into the
area there has been a communication
blackout in Gaza for days and it's
hindering Gras
efforts we are not even able to receive
emergency calls from citizens we are not
even able to use our navigation tools we
rely on our audio and visual skills to
reach the targeted areas on some
occasions we take light vehicles to
reach hospitals and ask victims about
locations of of the affected
areas it's already difficult for
families to stay in
touch I'm separated from my parents and
I can't reach out to them I do not know
how or where I can reunite with them
apart from this I have not been able to
reach my son for 2 days and I'm not able
to call him I don't know where he is I
can't rest I can't even sleep because
I'm not able to get in touch with many
of my family members
refugee camps across the strip are in
Ruins after Israeli air
strikes the number of Palestinians
seeking refuge in the south is
rising we can hardly survive my house
was bombed and leveled my family and I
are now homeless my sister and 10 of my
cousins were killed we were forced to
take shelter and tell AATA school there
my niece and nephew were killed then we
were forced to leave to another shelter
which was raided by the Israeli soldiers
I'm penniless how can I feed them we've
lost our
livelihoods it has been more than a 100
days since Israel launched its war on
Gaza but there is no end to the
humanitarian crisis Palestinians are
facing hunger and pain on a daily basis
their suffering is growing homelessness
is on the rise to many of them are
living in tense braving the cold and the
rain because they have nowhere else to
go hanim Mahmud Al jazer Rafa Southern
Gaza make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer